So now before we carry on, let's spend
a little bit of time comparing Epsilon
photography and Coded photography.
The aim so far, I've set for the concept
of Coded Photography is to encode into
a single image, information about
the environment, the photographic
signal from the environment, and then
we can add a post capture, after we've
captured the image decoded you actually
got more information about the scene.
We saw this example a little bit when
we did Light Field Cameras, right?
It captured the stack of pictures
into one image representation, and
then we were able to do thinks
like do things like paralens and
also change focal lens.
So Coded Photography basically is,
in that, that kind of a process
where we basically, encode into the
image itself additional information that
would allow us to extract more kinds
of images out of it at a later point.
Something that could actually capture
depth, parallax even focal planes, and
perhaps, additional information.
Epsilon Photography basically says,
rather than capture one image with all
of that information, let's capture a
series of images, a sequence of images,
a sequential set of images that may
have those different variations.
Take a picture, change the focal length,
take another picture.
That basically means, for example,
if there was a fast moving object
we would actually have trouble,
because we would really like
to have a much faster camera.
In the case of Coded Photography, since
it's doing all of that, and if it's fast
enough in computing all of this, it can
actually capture the image in one gulp.
So that's, basically one of
the big differences here.
Now of course, the space that
goes from Coded Photography and
Epsilon Photography couldn't be merged,
because we can actual combine them to be
able to generate null forms of images,
too.
So, one thing to note
about coded photography is
that each image that we may capture in a
Coded Photography signal would basically
mean that the neighborhood pixels
may have different radiations.
One pixel would have focal lens at
something, the other one may actually
have it at different one, and knowing
the code that relates both of them, and
knowing one pixel at the left or right
was captured, we can actually decode it,
and generate something new and
interesting.
Again, an example that comes to mind
is something I mentioned before,
bare patterns but knowing the pattern
that this one is r, this one is g, and
this one is b in a square pattern,
allowed us to decode the image.
In Epsilon Photography of course,
that variation is in time.
Now, all of this allows
us to now of course,
create the images that can
control light over time or space.
Because now we can capture a series of
images of one image that actually has
those radiations either in space or
in time, and
we can preserve details about
the recorded environment.
So, in essence, what I'm trying to get
to is there is this big space that we
could actually have between Coded
Photography and Epsilon Photography.
Both of them are useful,
and they may even overlap a little
bit in terms of what they can do.
These are just labels that we're
coming up to help us kind of define
the space of different
types of photography's
concepts that are related to
Computational Photography.
And of course, have both overlap
between both of them, and again,
at the end of the day, we're trying
to figure out how to capture the best
possible way of capturing an image that
we can actually render differently?